rabi how's morale sky-high I mean it is
Erin judge home run hi
I am in a hotel room so at least morale
in this room is really high I think
we're doing really well
okay what's your plan for the day and
preparing for the big debut taking over
for Chris Berman yeah I think that we
live in such an age of information that
I'm going to shut it all down I'm going
to sit on the deck here and just look at
boats going by like because there is so
much information exit velocity launch
angle longest home runs first home runs
who's pitching you know what size pants
they wore at eighth grade there is so
much of this I'm overwhelmed by how much
information there is and we're all into
information but at some point you just
kind of got to sit back and this is a
home run derby right let's let's watch
how far the ball goes isn't that what
home runs are all about you know we all
love the long ball so let's let's see
that unfold versus information overload
all right my take how would you how
would you do it I get a map because
there's gonna be a lot of long home runs
so you'd be able to tell us about the
surrounding counties and cities there in
Florida
you want to go with the cities you want
to go with the Fort Lauderdale's
focus and if you want to do that is that
so you would go with that no I would not
on that score no I would not
this is what I'm curious about so Rabi
you have the voice where you're not sure
it's going to be out but then there's
the voice where you know it's going to
be out what's the difference though when
you're calling a home run derby when
you're trying to make it seem like
you're not sure if it's going out and it
lands four hundred eighty eight feet
away like you can't go wow that he got a
lot of it did he get all of it and it
right like I just I think that was what
the backbackback was all about because
it allowed you to pull the ripcord you
know back back back back no it was so it
allows you to pull the ripcord
look I was at Fenway Park and if you do
play-by-play at Fenway Park you're
sitting up real high you're basically
eye level with the top of the Green
Monster and of course I had the
I think Oh is Pedroia and there's a
shallow drive to left whoa wait a second
the wind has it this one is over the
wall so I had a pop out to the shortstop
that ended up being a home run so there
so there's a hell of a lot of risk
involved in and sort of jumping the gun
on the home my sense is it's hopefully
sitting where we will be on that on that
field you'll be able to have a sense of
it but I'm looking to lay out a lot
tonight you know in TV parlance just lay
out and let it breathe and see where it
goes as opposed to every second of the
ball slide saying something that this is
there's going to be a lot of let the fan
at home really feel what it's like to be
there in a sense let them it you know at
home is that it no is that what that I
don't know if anybody has ever gotten
criticized for not talking I don't know
what Twitter is going to do a great
right I would agree with that
I would absolutely I have imagined the
judge stanton final and judge needs you
know three home runs in the last not
about 45 seconds to do what do I need to
be talking over that or can we all you
know appreciate you know there's one two
he wins there's the third I don't need
to describe it I think it lends itself
to one of those moments if in fact that
something like that happens talking to
Carl ravaged Ravi will be hosting
homeland Derby on the mothership tonight
at 8:00 Eastern but when you look at the
format of Home Run Derby I always
thought that you could put on a show as
McGwire did as Josh Hamilton did and not
win the home run derby and people look
back and remember those moments is there
a way it is there a way to tweak the
format that if I put up 28 in one round
that I know I'm going to be tired but
I've accumulated enough that would allow
me to get into the final like is there
something that you see where you can
improve homeland Derby well I think the
format now at least in a sense of and it
worked out really well this year you
know coming up with defending champ will
get the one seat even though Stanton
didn't have the most home runs and then
the rest of this
Falls in based on total homeland so you
do you are rewarded in a sense for
having the most homeruns in the first
half because you do then go second in
your in your head-to-head so if if you
and I are competing and I go first and I
hit 28 you know it forces you to hit 29
but if I only hit four you then only
have to hit five so you don't expend a
lot of that energy you know I'm sure we
could come up with a bar that if you
know if you do hit 20 or whatever the
magic number isn't around you get bonus
points I mean that would be probably
it's a way to do it you hit 20 you get
five extra innocence points and now the
other guy has to hit 21 and he would
beat you so you see if he doesn't get to
that number and you say those you know
you ultimately save those points but it
does it does make for each round but
again that would then require the second
hitter to try to get to that magic
number to get the bonus points that I
said we're trying to deter that because
you don't want to get tired and hitting
four in the final round what caught your
eye more the number of home runs in the
first half or how far these home runs
have gone I would say it's the number
but it's also the distance that a lot of
the non six-foot-seven 280-pound guys
are hitting it to me the bigger surprise
is not that Stanton and Judge and
Belanger and borer and Moustakas and
guys that are in this derby have hit the
home runs it's the idea that you know
Altuve who's a great hitter but else who
he's rising the ball all over the place
now for home lines that a lot of these
you know even in recent days here
Pedroia is getting caught for the Red
Sox I think the fact that the guys who
aren't homerun hitters are hitting home
runs the seven eight nine guys not to
mention George Springer has become Ricky
Henderson and Charlie Blackmon is Ricky
Henderson the number of home runs from
leadoff hitters this year is
astronomical we're going to end up with
well over 6,000 home runs which we've
never done before and after yesterday we
were as a sport ahead of last month's
pace which broke the previous month's
record now you do have three days off
here for the all-star break so that they
may
not see a record fall this month but I
think it's the other guys the smaller
guys who are hitting the home runs that
probably surprised me more than the
total I don't know if we've softened our
stance on this of you know wanting to
find out why and peds and all the you
know because it feels like the voters
Hall of Fame builders have softened
their stance on you know Barry Bonds or
Roger Clemens and not that we should and
look you know turn a blind eye to this
but we're not we're not beholding to
baseball records like we once were
because we were fooled once before we're
not going to be fooled again how does
that factor in on how people view the
numbers that are put you know judge is
putting up incredible numbers here do
you tell people look at judge and go you
know that's that's real or that's a
that's a great story or you know what I
just I just want to be entertained I
don't know if we change them last how
much we've changed in the last 15 years
how I think in judges case the same way
you are with LeBron or directly when
somebody is seemingly more physically
gifted or Tom Brady's age allows you to
sort of marvel is something he's doing
but others at that age are in judges
case you know the dude is Liberty is
LeBron I mean he's six a to 280 which is
a which is a basketball player or a
tight end playing baseball so I do think
there's a Marvel factor to it I don't
think the narratives today falls back on
the performance-enhancing I don't think
there's a lot of eyebrows raised I think
there's probably in at least speaking
with people who do watch the game some
level of acceptance that yeah they there
are going to be cheaters but I do think
that with the improve drug testing and
guys getting bang for half the season
there is I think a general acceptance
right or wrong that that the guys that
are doing the home runs to the level
that they're doing it are likely clean
but there are other factors going into
this and I do think a lot of times now
we're falling on the baseball's bound a
little tighter the guys are physically
stronger the relief pitchers especially
the middle relievers and back end guys
throw it harder and you know ball hits
back harder it flies further
I don't think that people have that same
concern or maybe care to your point
about who who and if anybody is trying
to beat the system using
performance-enhancing drugs but you know
I think you were with us when you know
we had the folks from the anti-doping
agency come and the idea was look the
cheaters are always going to try and
they're always going to be ahead of the
guys that are that are trying to stop it
so I think we're naive to think that
nobody is doing it but I do think it
would be it would be foolish to think
like we saw with McGwire and Sosa you
know in the late 90s that that that's
the cause for this there's uptick in
homeruns
are you more only on the Dodgers or the
ants truth that's a good question ah
both I you know I don't I don't want to
dodge the question I've been speaking
with people uh with Houston and you know
to me if you think about the Dodgers
even last night year in Cleveland there
are teams that I think in a postseason
series match up better with Houston than
they do with the Dodgers
only because title isn't Kershaw he's
not Scherzer they don't have that number
one ace who you might need they don't
have Corey Kluber they don't have Chris
Sale and I hate to say it because title
went into Yankee Stadium in a wild-card
game and absolutely stuffed it you know
he may II just he shut him down they won
the game they went on to lose in the
next round but he has the ability to do
that and yet I think you know if the
Indians get into a playoff and they end
up meeting the Astros that you're
looking at Kluber and Salazar and
Carrasco and Andrew Miller and Alan in
the back end that in a series they're
competitive with the Astros now if the
answer is go out and somehow pick up a
lick like exact like a Briton and
somebody else or a starter then yeah
they're damn good the offense is a joke
I mean it's great that yesterday because
you're into stats now I heard when we
started this the great style yesterday
was the five teams now that at the
all star break that have had the
greatest run differential three of the
previous the top three all went to the
World Series and currently on the list
are the Dodgers and the Astros at four
and five so we could just bang the rest
of the season the Dodgers and Astros
could start the World Series now and
that was a great number run differential
all-star break top five teams Houston
and Los Angeles four and five in the
previous three all played in the World
Series and both with at least 60 wins at
the all-star break
Carl ravaged with the call tonight the
voice of home run derby tonight 8:00
Eastern on the mothership and here is
that signature call from Carl ravish
you'll be hearing over and over tonight
right Frannie yes yes yes yes yes wait
is that it that you just heard a bit
that was it silence let's let it play
you just heard it lay out
it's called NAT sound here could give me
one of yours I will dick give me your
home run call and I will use it give you
one
give me a dad Patrick hold on call
because I when I sat on the set with you
on pitch Center and you would go into
the zoo that was I just had to sit back
and I I enjoyed it I watched so give me
the give me the home line call if you're
doing the Derby tonight Aaron judge
already with 19 home runs and here's the
pitch going just just a silo just out of
a gun that's it like they let's not joke
about it we don't think in anybody
we're grown-ups here all you're doing is
disseminating information on all you're
going to tell people is you're in the
building you're you knew it when you
heard it going alright then layout and
we're yeah just let it breathe yeah let
it breathe go let it breathe I'll give
you I'll give you a gun you got it okay
all right yes yes yes let's go have fun
tonight all right I'll do that thanks
very much for having me hi buddy that's
like our wrench the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience